one of the ways that we work here at
Legacy is anything that we're going to
build full-size that's a pretty decent
scale will do in what we call a maquette
basically oppose scale down figure we
print smaller size anywhere between 10
inches and 18 inches to get a
representation of what we're going to
print full-size this is kind of like my
safe haven this is my utopia this room
it's a pretty special room a lot of what
you see on the big screen this is where
most of them come to life for the first
time off of this machine that's exciting
this is real now he's in three
dimensions it's official it just blows
me away kind of is that's the one thing
about 3d printing it's taking something
from the digital world and bring it into
physical world for the first time so
it's almost like a delivery room in a
hospital you're in here you take them
something off the bed it's you know it's
been being created for hours and it's
been weeks upon weeks that you've been
talking about it and seeing it on the
screen and then all of a sudden you have
a representation of what you're about to
embark on for the next month you know it
says it just gets you more excited you
can see it this is real it's happening
and this is the first stage of it all
the detail is there so far people can
take a look at him for reference at
times the guys that are in there
sculpting detail back into the foam mill
head that we did can look at this for
reference placement or just in general
talking this is why these visual
references are great to have and then at
the end of the project they also turn
into great handout collectibles for some
of the key players on the TV boxes in
our I don't break them we need them for
tomorrow
go to wired.com for the entire giant
creature series